Eli Bildner, thank you so much for joining me
on 20 Minute Leaders.
It is such a pleasure to have you here.
It is a pleasure to be here.
Thanks so much for having me.
Where are you calling from?
Oakland, California. Not too far.
Oakland, California. Wonderful.
Well I'm in Southern California
so definitely not too far.
But I'm originally, now
situated in Palo Alto.
So, Eli, 20 minutes is not gonna do nearly
enough justice for everything that
I wanna cover from Yale,
to Stanford MBA
to early employee at Coursera
Chan Zuckerberg Initiative,
and Bloomberg Philanthropies,
working on education and housing.
Oh my God. Where do we even start?
Eli, where do we start?
I don't know man. You tell me.
All right. Let's start from growth of tech,
move to philanthropy,
and then let's talk about this
non-linear nature of your career
because just before we started this,
we started talking about this idea that
you know, today people don't have to choose
a linear path. So, you know
talk to me about being an early employee
at Coursera.
Andrew Ng is one of the, a role model of mine.
Talk to me a little bit about what you were
doing there and the grow that you helped lead.
Yeah. Totally. Andrew is a great guy.
Everyone's got these sort of early
embarrassing early career memories
and I wasn’t so young when I was at Coursera.
I traveled with Andrew to China
a couple times as we were trying
to build up business there.
Oh yeah, Fulbright in China.
I forgot to mention that.
Yeah, this background in China, and yeah
I can tell you all about that in a second.
But I was having a little bit of a
tough time emotionally,
just not sure about what I was doing,
and I was having dinner with Andrew
and I just kinda like broke down and crying.
I was sitting there with Andrew
in a hotel in China
and he was like comforting me and trying to like,
So he's a really caring and sweet guy
and a great leader, and obviously
an incredible thinker.
But I had a very fun sort of personal
moment with him. I really respect him.
Well then I can now share
that one of my life's goals
is to have a crying session with Andrew Ng.
There we go well it can happen.
There's hope for you yet.
Yeah. So, I mean maybe to connect
the career piece
to my experience at Coursera piece,
I ended up taking a job at Coursera
early on, really not without
much kind of strategy behind it.
I was really interested in
what it would mean for the way
people access education to change.
I've been involved in starting
in the very early stages
an Online Coding Bootcamp and,
and one thing I didn’t appreciate
coming to Coursera is that,
at an early company where there is
so much growth, like really,
you end up dictating your role as much as
the company does.
And I came in with this experience
having worked in China.
Really, a couple months after I joined,
Coursera was starting to think about
other opportunities for us in China
and it turned out that I was really the only one
at the company who had business development
and partnership experience in China.
And so I was tasked -
And you speak Mandarin fluently.
I speak Mandarin maybe more
fluently at the time.
And I was tasked to kind of help
project manage this effort and that
that became a big part of my role.
So, it definitely something I try to share
with people who are thinking about
kind of early stage career stuff,
whenever you come in to a role,
you know think about
what is in your portfolio,
even if it’s not something that was in the
job description you signed up for
they're probably,
particularly at that stage of a company,
there are a lot of opportunities to
to bring that stuff to there.
So, I came to Coursera and then,
I was there from 2013 through late 2015.
And then went to Stanford to do an MBA.
And saw Coursera grow from 40 people
35, 40 people to probably 200
and really interesting time in the company
and in the world.
And then, after Coursera,
I'd done some work in philanthropy before,
but sort of have since graduating
business school, I have worked more
in a non-profits and philanthropy.
And yeah, happy to talk about pros and cons
of those two very different worlds.
But I've seen both sides of that.
How do you go from seeing
a great company growing so fast,
a lot of it under also your initiatives,
and then you're going to a business school
which inherently business school, it's business
and a lot of the business school classes
I really hope one day I'll be able
to do that as well.
I heard about the touchy-feely class
of the GSB
and all these different experiences.
It doesn’t seem like they are guiding
necessarily for philanthropy
and for non-profits.
Where did that even come from?
Yeah, I mean there are probably,
I don’t know, fewer than five people
in my class of 400 who went into non-profits
or at least operating non-profits.
So, not a huge focus.
Although there's a lot at Stanford
around social innovation, and yeah
there's a lot of good exposure there.
But it's not part of the culture
and part of it either. But one thing that
I learned at Coursera that has stuck with me,
is, you know companies love to talk about
their social mission and their impact
and we're a mission-driven company,
and like you know,
I think truth be told,
a lot of the time that -
if can I get to say this on the show -
bulls**t it's like more marketing
than anything.
Definitely.
I work in a community
non-profit now, but I'm also like,
I mean there's nothing wrong
with running a successful business
and serving customers
and serving employees well.
And how you run it really matters.
And you don’t need to dress it up
with this whole like you know
"We're a mission driven Fintech company
working on payment solutions"
Well yeah, I'm sure it's good for the world
but just own, like you're a great company.
There's nothing wrong with that.
So, and yeah, what I came to believe
through my work at kind of mission-driven
community, I really respect Coursera,
is that, if you're a for profit,
and particularly venture backed company,
you're always gonna be migrating
towards your highest growth and
highest margin opportunities.
And at Coursera, that meant like
Coursera was never been,
was never gonna be a company that was focused
on serving the most vulnerable
people in the world.
That just not what it was built to do.
It was built to scale really quickly
through venture capital
and through technology
And grow, and migrate towards
the best business opportunities for the company
which have turned out to be
in corporate learning and development
and in traditional degree programs.
I think that's great.
I really believe in what Coursera is doing
in the world. I'm really proud of having
been a part of the company.
I love the people there but
it's not enough that, you know
Our economy does not solve necessarily
for the problems of the
most traditionally underserved and
most vulnerable in the population
that's just a fact
So, I knew, coming out of my experience
at Coursera, that I wanted to think more,
and work more on, anchor on a population
as opposed to anchoring on a business model
and non-profits are really good at that.
I love it.
Yeah.
I think it's incredible.
And I think this take on impact,
and what really needs to be solved.
That’s really inspiring.
But then, you go and you actually join
some of the most notable organizations
in the world for this type of work.
You, tell me a little bit about this
Chan Zuckerberg Initiative
and what you were doing there
and then the Bloomberg Philanthropy?
Yeah, I've always been a big fan of China.
You know, create your own career opportunities.
And so much of it just has to do with timing.
And during my MBA summer,
I was just thinking about what to do.
I got connected from a friend and a mentor
to someone who is basically the kind of
chief of staff or intermediary of
Mark Zuckerberg and Priscilla Chan's
philanthropy which hadn't launched then.
And she was helping them stand it up.
And so I became their first,
Oh, it was just starting back then.
It just starting. Yeah.
I became their first intern.
And I think I just always had been drawn
to kind of these early stage experiences
but I think philanthropy, you know,
each sector I've been involved in
whether it's businesses,
whether its philanthropy,
whether its operating non-profits,
they all have an important role.
And one thing that’s very powerful
about philanthropy is its
convening power. Its agenda setting power.
It's sort of like the medium in that way
in that it's remarkable how little money
it takes to change a conversation
or to create a conversation.
And so, I'm really
What does that mean?
So, like as an example,
particularly with public actors,
or state governments, local governments,
even the federal government,
there's so little, and even companies
You know, very very few companies,
organizations, policy actors have
discretionary money just lying around.
And so, if you're one of these actors,
and you wanna try something really new,
you really have very few places to turn
and philanthropy is one of them.
And so, you know even if you're,
So just to give you a specific example,
I was working with Bloomberg Philanthropies,
evaluating a bunch of different programs that
they might invest in to spur investment in
career and technical education
so helping students enter
mostly non-degree pathways,
or help equip them with skills.
The State of Delaware was looking to do
something really different with how they
structured career and technical education
and they were looking for funding to do it
So I went down there to
understand what they were thinking.
They'd ask for a few million dollars.
Now, the state of Delaware,
their entire budget for K12
I don't know what it is off the top of my head,
but it's certainly hundreds of millions of dollars.
But for a grant the request of $3,000,000
they brought out the governor, a senator
the CEO of a major company.
Like that is what the promise
of a few million dollars
of discretionary capital could unlock.
And so, if you're a funder,
you have this unbelievable,
you know, everyone’s gonna answer your call.
And it's a tremendous power and privilege
that comes with a lot of responsibility
in my mind.
But if you're someone like, you don't have
millions of dollars to give away
it makes working in philanthropy
interesting because if you can help funders
channel their energy in productive ways
like you really do have a good shot of
changing conversations and
setting agendas.
Wow. No that's insane.
So then you move on to Bloomberg and
do you do something similar over there
as what you did in Chan Zuckerberg Initiative?
Largely. With Chan Zuckerberg Initiative
I was focused on helping them think
about how they might improve
housing affordability in California
and particularly in the Bay Area.
And then at Bloomberg,
my work was more around
higher education and
career education pathways.
But similar kind of philanthropic advising,
which is just, it's of these things
you know, going back to the thread
we started before the interview
around career, that you know
sometimes you just learn that you have
a skillset or that, you know,
you kind of end up in a network and
and then building a portfolio of projects
around that can be really rewarding.
So for me, part of that
is just been getting to advice
different philanthropies on how they
spend their money
and what projects they pursue.
So what is Concourse Education?
I believe you're wearing, I believe the
the logo is on your sweatshirt, right?
Yeah I'm wearing my Concourse hoodie
So Concourse is a non-profit
that I co-founded about three years ago.
That was my first take at starting
and operating a non-profit and we're a college program
that helps particularly low-income
working adults in California
at an accelerated low-cost
Bachelor’s Degree.
Wow. So, you're helping them actually
achieve their dream.
And how do you actually go about doing that?
So, we have a,
our headline goal is to dramatically
simplify the college experience
for working adults who are, you're competing
for their attention with kids, with work
with all the complications of life
and particularly for people who might be
working more than one job, or low-wage jobs.
And so, you know they don't have time
to be on the phone for two hours
with the financial aid office
or try to figure out what forms to file
or you know, if they need academic help
to figure out the then different places
they might go to get it like college needs
to be designed for them
And so that's what we've done.
We basically redesigned the
college experience to really serve
that student population and we have
done that by partnering with two
accredited universities.
So we're a stand alone 51c3 non-profit.
We've kind of a white label-ish partnership
with these universities where we
essentially ride off their accreditation
and their access to financial aid
to again create this better college experience
for working students.
Incredible.
So, Eli, over all these years working
with non-profits,
Trying to solve really meaningful issues.
I mean, these are not simple issues to solve.
You know it's one thing to say,
"Okay I'm gonna do startup that
you know, makes you a better runner
with a device" or whatever.
It's another thing to say,
"Okay, I'm gonna tackle this problem of
low-income people trying to
attain a college education while
going through the different adversities
that life has to offer."
I'd love to sort of pick your brain
over the last few minutes that we have.
What are some of your earned secrets
over this non-profit sector about
what does it take to go and really
challenge these big big problems?
Yeah. It's a great question.
I think one is the just right size of expectations.
You know, non-profits, you're not
gonna change the world in two years.
They’re really slow build organizations
and for a couple reasons.
One is the problems, as you referenced
are really intractable.
These are hard problems to solve.
Two, you know almost definitionally
they sort of are non-market problems
and there's market failures so you're kind of
you're running against headwinds.
And then three, in terms of what is the
what is the lifeblood
that keeps non-profits going?
Obviously it's called profit capital.
Even for an earned revenue non-profit like us
where we actually earn money from our services
we still need our profit capital to grow.
And philanthropies are so different from VC.
So, just to give you a sense
of what that looks like in practice.
With VC, if you're an associate at a VC firm
you're looking for deals where it's a 10x,
a 20x, a 100x.
That's gonna be a good portfolio of work.
If you're asking for money from a philanthropy,
they have a very different orientation.
First of all, it's not so clear what a 10x,
or a 100x is.
Sure. But it's more in the impact for,
the whole conversation is centered more
around impact rather than return.
It's centered more on impact and more on
than more on a return.
But a program officer is not necessarily
incentivized to go for the riskiest proposition.
Because even if it does pay off,
paying off could take place over
10 to 20 years.
And things that go really badly,
go really badly in like six to 12 months.
So, just from an incentive perspective,
philanthropy not incentivized to
really do super risky things.
At the same time,
philanthropy very reasonably.
Because non-profits are not
you know, most non-profits are not
on a track to become self-sustaining
on earned revenue,
you know, if you're a philanthropy,
you don’t wanna set up a non-profit with a
$5 million annual budget in year one.
And then year two, they have that cliff
where it's like, if we don't raise $5 million,
we're dead.
So, non-profits, the way they work
is they're constantly,
we're constantly raising our next month
of runway all the time.
And what this means, from resourcing perspective
is it's really hard to invest in
like a five or 10,
or even a two-year time prize
like in a for profit company.
So, I think the headline in all of this is that
non-profit philanthropy there's really
valuable places to work.
They are trade-offs
and one of the trade-offs is that
it can feel really sloggy
and it's more of a slow burn than
most of the time in for profits.
So, do you see yourself,
we talked about this idea of non-linear
career pathways.
Do you see yourself going back
to the sort of the business sector
and the for-profit sector?
Or is it something that you're really
passionate about that you see yourself
going forever?
Yeah. I'm not an idealogue about any particular
organization of an entity like you know,
some companies are great,
that's for profits, there are non-profits,
that are great that believe in
the importance and the role of government.
And so, my hope and maybe to
end the conversation where we started
I think, I learned about myself that
I love having a portfolio
of things I work on.
And so, I would be surprised,
although not shocked if I,
if I never spend 10 or 15 or 20 years
on one thing in my career.
It's just not exactly who I am.
Or not who I've been.
Although we all can change.
One thing I like to share with people
who are thinking about their own careers
and career trajectories is that
that's okay. Like I think for me
I felt that was very not okay for awhile
and I was talking to a mentor of mine
and he basically asked,
"Have you ever considered that this is okay?
Like this is not a problem to solve?"
But maybe a ... to solve around?
Totally. Exactly. Well played.
So, if anyone's listening to this
who's thinking about their own career,
and career design like you know,
maybe look at the patterns
that you've created in your early career
and think critically about
if you've problematized them.
Is this actually a problem?
And if it feels like a problem,
how might I make it not a problem?
And sometimes that can be
I think liberating.
Definitely. No, no I love it.
You know, we have just about
a minute and a half left.
And I have so many more questions.
But, I have the most important one.
And I'm gonna put you on the spot.
So, I apologize in advance.
I'd love for you to tell me three words
that would best describe yourself.
That you would best describe yourself
Or that one of your co-founders
would describe you
or Andrew Ng would describe you as?
Oh man. Okay.
Probably, curious.
Earnest. Very earnest.
And neurotic.
Like a good Jewish guy.
Very neurotic.
I love it. Does it help with business?
Sometimes, it creates a lot mental anx
but sometimes helps I suppose. Yeah.
I love it. Eli, thank you so much for the time.
Thank you so much for the inspiration.
I mean, this non-linear path
that you're talking about
I think it's something that's really,
it's really ...
And I had this really interesting talk,
with Alyssa Rapp, who is a GSB lecturer
I talked with her awhile back
and I believe we already
by the time this airs
her video would already be published.
And one of the most interesting things
that she was talking about was her
non-linear path that she got
that she saw her mother go through
And today, really we have this privilege.
And especially that we get to go to
these really great institutions
and we get to harness all these different skillsets
It's almost a waste not to go and try to
put our feet in, to dive into different waters
and to test different fields
and see where we can make an impact
n various sectors. Not just one.
Well put. Yeah. Toda raba. It's been a pleasure.
Thanks so much and great to be here.
Thank you and we'll need to catch up
over a beer when I'm back in Palo Alto
and this whole covid thing is over.
Beautiful. Let's do it
Cool. Take care. Bye bye Eli.
Thank you.